what is it like to work with Peter tio
tell me about the day you found out he's
gonna be publicly supporting Trump
because I don't think that you voted for
Trump no I'm not a trump supporter I
don't think anybody in the firm is
except for him so what is that like when
you go to a meeting with him and it's a
super polarizing world where people are
freaking out about Trump and he is
publicly going out and saying this is my
guy we've got to get him in office and
rounding up Silicon Valley to bring him
there I know it's a hard question but
yeah what happens to this caption you
know unlike what seems like a lot of
people in Silicon Valley I am a firm
believer in people do not have to be the
same people do not have to have the same
exact opinions people do not have to
have the same exact views I love working
with people that have different views
than me in fact I think one of the
reasons why Founders Fund is so
successful is because of that our
debates are large and many and plentiful
and people have very different opinions
and we thrive on that so no I'm not a
Donald Trump supporter the fact that
Peter is okay great let's talk about it
it also it shapes the fact that we can
have conversations that no other firm in
Silicon Valley have can't have and not
only that but the people that shy away
from talking to somebody based on who
they supported politically man I mean
that seems like one of the largest
problems in this country now and the
thing that's making the separation even
more than it already has been like I'm
that you if I can get anything one thing
can change in Silicon Valley over the
next you know couple years it's the
ability for people there to actually
just talk with people with different
political views than them
[Applause]